foreign
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
welcome to Smart Castle Cinemas
everybody I'm your host for tonight
Kevin Smith and thanks for coming out
spending the end of 2022 with me uh
generally uh at a New Year's Eve
Gathering uh somebody gets [ __ ]
wasted and whips out their wiener at the
end of the night we're gonna start the
night that way and
and in order to do so I've asked
castlekeeper Ernie O'Donnell to whip out
my wiener give it up for shotgun
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
I imagine she feels like she's being
sold because we're like
high is bitter for Kevin's wiener uh oh
[ __ ] do you want to launch those
you do it all got the mic I'll take
three volunteers kids come on up who
wants to shoot off the [ __ ] cannons
bam I'll get you one
bam how are you my friend hold on to
that bam come over to this side if
you're gonna do it
well we'll do it on this side all right
so one here one there and then one right
here but don't shoot it in anybody's
[ __ ] face particularly not stew we
need him
um it has been a red hot minute since
I've been on this side of the country
when the time change and it always felt
like a bit of a fraud being out west and
we were like happy New Year because it
happened three [ __ ] hours early and
[ __ ] like when we watched the ball drop
it's recorded and [ __ ] so it's gonna be
[ __ ] nice to be here and do it and
honestly folks I couldn't thank you
enough for spending it with us here
tonight you sold us out man I appreciate
the [ __ ] out of that
uh at 11 59 we're going to get a clock
up here man and 11 59 is going to happen
at every second kids holding the Cannons
you know how to operate them yeah you
could do it right from your dick
probably a very good idea
uh when it happens blast out again and
nobody's face over the crowd we're
looking for arcing ropes of jizm of
confetti kids
uh okay we got a clock up yes there it
is ladies and gentlemen we are looking
at the last few seconds of 2022 man it's
been an amazing year for me I hope it
was an amazing year for you but this
fucker's dead and now we head into 2023
together kids right here right now man
30 seconds left to the end of this
wretched year
and we get to end it together it's smart
Castle my friends
people as we are
2022 here in Atlantic Highlands New
Jersey I want to thank you for being
here
10 seconds left let's do it kids nine
eight seven six five four three
everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
you could do it you could do it
twist it help them out
[Music]
oh my God this is so hot
oh
excellent [ __ ] job
give it up for our Cannon ears
[Music]
my friends welcome to 2023 everybody
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
greetings everybody and welcome to the
AKA ask Kevin every Saga has a 10-year
anniversary ladies and gentlemen and
this is what happens with Jay and Silent
Bob get old off Kevin Smith
[Music]